be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
so with Marvel's Avengers 2 age of
Ultron coming out one of the big
questions a lot of people have is what's
the deal with the vision a lot of people
want to know about the vision because in
truth model hasn't really revealed a lot
of information about the visions role or
what you'll be doing in the Avengers 2
age of Ultron all we really know is that
Paul Bettany will be playing the role of
the of the vision and so again we don't
know how far deep this is going to go
and so what we're going to do in this
video is we're going to talk about the
vision in Marvel Comics that way you
guys will have a frame of reference when
you guys are actually looking at the
vision and other Marvel Cinematic
Universe now the first thing that we
have to recognize here is that the
vision that we see the one that we most
commonly think of in Marvel Comics
is actually not the first one the
original vision up here during the
Golden Age of Marvel Comics and Marvel
mystery issue number 13 but keep in mind
as we've discussed in previous videos in
relation to the Golden Age of comics
when the Golden Age was really coming to
an end when it was really beginning to
taper off Marvel and I guess timely an
atlas comics and even DC Comics
themselves we're really beginning to
move comic books in a direction more
along the lines of mystery and suspense
and sci-fi and so on and so Roy Thomas
at the time had really delved into this
realm by introducing the original person
named the vision now this vision was a
being named arcus anarchist was kind of
this intergalactic I guess police
officer or bounty hunter of sorts and
the way the role had played out here was
that some scientists had effectively
opened a portal from this to the smoke
world which is quite literally what it
was called and that this version of the
vision was able to actually enter the I
guess earth-616 continuity that's how we
want to refer to it and he began the
process of basically fighting crime and
so on and so forth now again keeping up
with a lot of characters who were
introduced during this timeframe around
World War two prior to World War two and
so on he had joined the forces of the
Allied powers fighting against the Axis
powers in World War two and again this
really just kind of ties into a lot of
the comic themes that we had seen where
a lot of characters were basically
pro-american propaganda now the vision
that we most commonly think of that is
to say the one that we'll see in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe first appeared
in The Avengers issue number 57 now the
way this character came about
was really more of a I guess a
compromise between Stanley and Roy
Thomas Stanley wanted to introduce a new
kind of character he wanted to introduce
somebody that had never been seen before
but Roy Thomas wanted to bring back the
Golden Age vision this made sense
because a golden age vision was
established he had had interactions with
the original Human Torch he was a
character that people going into the
Silver Age who had previously read the
Golden Age already knew of and so it
would be very easy for Marvel to really
just kind of build on this continuity
and go forward and so ultimately they
sort of agreed at the very least to have
an Android version but again to calm the
vision but to make him a totally
different person here instead of being
an alien and so what we find is that
with the ventures issue number 57 when
the vision first appears the vision
simply just there he just arrives we
don't really know how we got there we
don't know where he came from all we
know is that he seems to be an enemy of
the Avengers and the reason why we know
this is because the first act that he
commits is to attack Janet Van Dyne now
the way the story begins to unfold Janet
Van Dyne apparently is going to spend
the night at home as opposed to going
out with Hank Pym because remember at
this time the two of them are romantic
couple they're not actually married yet
and so when she arrives inside of her
home almost immediately she's attacked
by the vision now of course she goes
through the normal process that we saw
with superheroes where she shrinks down
to a wasp form she tries to escape and
when she shuts the door she presumably
believes that the visions going to be
trapped inside and there's really no way
for him to break through but what the
vision does is he actually I guess moves
through a wall and again continues to
pursue a pursue Janet Van Dyne continues
to pursue the wasp and so is she's
really kind of fighting for her life
here a Hank Pym realizes what's going on
he turns into his giant man form and he
goes to try to rescue a Janet Van Dyne
but at the same time while this is
happening the vision for some reason or
another which we don't know simply seems
to have some sort of pain in his mind
and then simply just collapses and so
once Hank Pym arrives at the apartment
of Janet Van Dyne they agree the best
thing for them to do is to basically
take the take the vision back to
Avengers headquarters that way they can
really analyze his body they can figure
out what's going on with him they can
try to understand why it is that the
vision is doing what he's doing and so
again what we find is we continue with
Avengers number 57 is that the The
Avengers are called together and
at Avengers headquarter of course again
they begin to look over the body and
look over the design of the vision and
what happens here is that the vision I
guess wakes up from having passed out
and then immediately attacks the attacks
the Avengers and when he does he
basically is really reciting this kind
of this logic basically telling them he
was designed for the purpose of
attacking them but what's really
interesting here is that is that black
panther seems to pick up on something we
didn't really notice before in the sense
that what the vision is doing is
basically acting like someone who's in a
trance and the sense that he's been more
or less hypnotized or he's been assigned
a task but he doesn't know why he's
doing this all he knows is that he's
doing it because he was told to and so
the vision seemingly some seems to stop
his attack on the Avengers and he begins
to basically talk with them and again
try to figure out what's going on uh so
what he does is he begins to probe his
mind he begins to look into why it is
that this is happening and what he
realizes or what he remembers is that he
was created by Ultron to destroy the
Avengers and so the Avengers realizing
of course a threat that Ultron face in
this sense they had previously faced
Ultron one time before of course his
initial introduction into Marvel Comics
immediately go on the offensive and of
course the vision says that he feels as
though he's not supposed to be attacking
them and to some former fashion they're
supposed to be allies here and so what
the vision does is he agrees to lead the
Avengers to the headquarters or I guess
to the base of operations for Ultron and
what we do is we switch to Ultron here
and what we learn is that this was all
part of Ultron's plan that Ultron had
initially created the vision and the
vision again as a he had said via told
us was designed to kill the Avengers but
that should this have failed that it was
basically a subroutine a backup program
installed in the vision so that his
programming would would I guess allow
him or require him to bring the Avengers
to Ultron so that Ultron could destroy
the Avengers on his own and so what
happens is of course as the group enters
Ultron's base the Avengers are basically
trapped that really kind of confined in
this room with these ever closing walls
that would inevitably squish them and
kill them off and the vision confronts
Ultron and what's really interesting
here is that the vision really conducts
himself like a rebellious subordinate
like someone who is I guess who was a
creative for a single purpose but is
rebelling against that purpose and so he
tells Ultron that ultimately he doesn't
want to do this that he doesn't want to
fight the Avengers he wants to join the
Avengers
moreso than that he wants to know what
his purpose is he wants to know why he's
here the reason why he was made of
course Ultron refuses to tell them this
and in response of course Ultron
seemingly attached the vision and the
vision seems to be able to afford his
attack and Ultron seems destroyed in the
process and so what we do is we pick up
with Avengers issue number 58 and an
Avengers issue number 58 we get a little
more to this story we actually see more
or less that we're picking up directly
after Avengers issue number 57 then what
happens here is the Avengers agreed to
induct the vision into their ranks but
only once they actually find out what
his purpose is why it is that he was
made and even more than that who he is
and so again as I continue here what
happens is that Hank Pym recalls making
some kind of an Android but he doesn't
really remember what it was and so what
the group does is they travel back to
the old suburban lab of Hank Pym and
again what this does this actually picks
up with our deaf injury I'm sorry our
Ultron discussion where we learn about
why Ultron was made we actually learned
about the fact that Hank Pym was the one
that made all Tron which of course
you're welcome to check out our Ultron
video if you want to get into that but
what Hank Pym also recalls is that at
some point along the line that the
memories or I guess the mind the tapes
of Wonder Man had been stored within the
confines of this lab and that they're
now missing and so what happens of
course Hawkeye asks who Wonder Man was
and Iron Man begins to explain here and
what we find is that as somewhere along
the line a man named Simon Williams had
approached the Avengers and wanted to
join their ranks but the problem here is
that he was suffering from an illness
that was going to kill him of course due
to the fact that he had super-strength
that he seemed to be a pretty solid guy
the avengers inducted him into their
ranks but the problem is that Simon
Williams was a double agent but he
didn't really seem to be a double agent
I guess of his own accord what had
happened here was that he was basically
being held against his own will by a
Baron Zemo and Baron Zemo had basically
been blackmailing him telling him that
he would not given the cure to his
disease unless he fought on his behalf
and so what Wonder Man did is he lured
the Avengers into a trap and in the
process Baron Zemo revealed that his
intention was to kill the Avengers and
so because Wonder Man didn't wanna
partake in this he actually freed Thor
but in the process biram Simo escaped
and with him went the Cure and so a
Wonder Man had died
the arms of the Avengers but what hank
pym had done is he had scanned the mind
of wonder man and when he did he had
stored these scans in his lab and so
when ultron had emerged when ultron had
rebelled against hank pym when he was
first created and had wiped hank PEM's
mind of anything resembling memories
read about ultron that when Hank Pym
left
Ultron began reassembling a lab and what
Ultron did is he took the memories or
took the mind patterns of Wonder Man and
he used them to create the vision and so
what we find as this issue as issue
number 58 begins to come to an end is
that we pick up with again the Avengers
as they're talking about the vision and
what they decide is that because the
vision had basically risked his life to
save them but their best bet here is to
let the vision become a member of the
Avengers because as far as they're
concerned he's done everything he can to
prove himself as a worthy member and so
what this does is just basically March
the time in which the vision will
officially become a member of the
Avengers moving forward for quite some
time in Marvel Comics and so following
the appearance of the vision in Marvel
Comics what we saw is that a 1968 Marvel
had Avengers issues number 66 and 69
going then what this was was basically
the vision continuing to deal with the
idea that he was more or less a copy of
Wonder Man and in fact and issue number
66 what we find that the vision actually
visits the grave of Wonder Man because
again this is very much an element that
will stick with the vision for those of
you guys who were fans of Star Trek
whether you were fans of the original
Star Trek or the next generation the
vision can best be compared to Spock or
data respectively in the sense that he
was a cyborg or I guess a synthetic that
had elements of him that made him human
but he was always aspiring to become
more human he was always aspiring to I
just developed this identity of his own
so that you could kind of break away
from the shadow of Wonder Man but he was
something that he was never really able
to do and so what we found over the
course of this series of issues number
66 through 69 is that vision is
ultimately taken over again by Ultron
and by virtue of this action he's forced
into making an adamantium body for
Ultron's so of course we see that Ultron
is defeated at the hands of the Avengers
as we would expect and so what we do is
we move on to Avengers issue number 75
and with issues number 75 in 1970 what
we find is that Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch return to the Avengers and
this is really an important element here
because what this is going to do is
effectively set the stage for a lot of
the events that come forward later on
with issue number 108 in 1973 The
Scarlet Witch I guess in the vision
officially started dating one another
now it's very subtle and the way that
this is done this is really just an
instance where by the vision is
basically comforting The Scarlet Witch
where he tells her that if she needs to
she can basically cry on his shoulder
and of course we see the Thor charms
then it simply tells the tells the group
to give these two some time which we
know that just by virtue of human
interaction and the way things work that
ultimately this will lead into a
relationship between the two of them and
an Avengers issue number 109 Marvel more
or less cements this but they really
only cement it by the two of them
holding hands and the reason for this
the reason why Marvel doesn't overtly
have the two of them showing any real
manner of affection there's for a couple
reasons the first is because of the
comics code Authority of course the
comics code Authority established in
1954 was basically a set of guidelines
we're about comic books had to basically
print the material or write the material
in such a way to where it was respectful
of society at the time then one of the
conditions was that there couldn't be
any overt sexual activity between
between two individuals it is to say at
the time when this comic had come out in
the 1970s and especially you know when
the previous era in the 1960s when comic
books were very big during the Silver
Age individuals were able to show
affection to one another but they could
only really do it by virtue of maybe
holy hands or by virtue of saying they
care about one another they couldn't
invite I guess I couldn't involve
themselves in overt sexual activities
such as kissing and so all they really
had the two of them do was just hold
hands and so in 1975 with giant size
Avengers issue number four
The Scarlet Witch and the vision
officially marry one another now in
truth as Roy Thomas had told us this
really just kind of was done in
practicality this really just kind of
made sense here and the reason why was
because you had two individuals you had
the vision who was on a hunt for I guess
to enhance his humanity to become more
human but more so than that he wanted to
fit in he wanted companionship and then
you had the Scarlet Witch you had this
very screwed up and isolated life and
who in a lot of ways wanted some measure
of normalcy
on the two of them just kind of latched
onto one another
kind of found themselves although I
would go as far as to say this
relationship was ultimately doomed to
failure because it was one that was
founded under the guise of two
individuals dealing with the negative
aspects of their lives as opposed to the
positive aspects and so what happens is
that seven years after this in 1982
Marvel launches I guess a solo series
called the vision and Scarlet Witch and
the reason why they had done this was
because there was some interest I guess
a moderate amount of interest with
regards to the Scarlet Witch and the
vision in terms of the relationship but
what we had found was that when when
bill Mantlo and Rik lien already had put
this contest coming together this series
together there wasn't as much interest
as Marvel thought and so the series only
ran for about four issues but muffled
brought it back in volume two and 1985
with sting Steve Englehart and Richard
Howell and what they did is they
introduced the concept of the Scarlet
Witch having children having two twin
boys now she was able to conceive by
virtue of magic but that was really the
only information that we got we didn't
really know exactly how this had
happened the Scarlet Witch was simply
just I guess has just informed her
husband that she was pregnant one day
and so what we saw was that in 1984
Marvel launched Avengers West Coast or
what would later become known as the
West Coast Avengers or at least that
would kind of be given the the name that
a lot of fans would take on for the team
but what we saw was that Roger Stern had
initially pushed this and this was
really just a way for Marvel to branch
out into the realm of introducing more
Avengers titles to the possibility of
having separate teams on different
different parts of the country but what
we saw was at a 1998 I'm sorry 1988 the
Scarlet Witch and vision had joined the
team and again for the most part they
continued on about their normal roles
can turn their normal acts as part of
the West Coast Avengers there were
simply superheroes engaging in different
activities and so from here what we do
is we continue with volume 1 of West
Coast Avengers and we see that in 1989
John Byrne runs a series called I guess
the Vision Quest which takes place in
issues 42 through 45 and what had
happened here is that John Byrne who was
now the writer and the penciler I guess
the artist for for this particular story
didn't like the direction that Marvel
had taken with the vision and the
Scarlet Witch for him it seemed very
silly that we would have an Android that
would exist in the realm of the vision
an Android that was hunting for humanity
he also didn't like the idea
of it magic in different things like
that had basically taken tick in the
place of actual contraception between
the Scarlet Witch and the vision and so
what he did here is he basically wipe
the slate clean he started all over
again and what happened is that over the
course of this series the the vision is
basically disassembled he's destroyed
and Hank McCoy is long along with
various other people so I Hank Pym along
with various other people try to
reassemble him but ultimately they just
can't quite get the element that made
him human that is to say they can't
replicate the mine patterns of Simon
Williams of wonder man now the reason
why they can do it is for a couple
reasons one because they can't actually
find the patterns to do it but two while
Simon Williams is alive during the West
Coast Avengers well he's been restored
back to the marvel landscape he's
unwilling to do this and the reason why
is because for Simon Williams his brain
patterns being copied were done against
his will and he felt like it was
stripping him of what it was it made him
who he was that there was basically a
copy of him running around out there and
so what John Byrne did is he gave us the
vision back but the vision had let had
lost all the coloring to himself he was
actually just a pure white individual
with a pure white cape not only that he
was devoid of all emotion and so what
this did was effectively create a rift
between him and the Scarlet Witch in
addition we learned that the Scarlet
Witch his children weren't actually real
they weren't really children and instead
they were the shards of Mephisto and so
everything that had really established
this family element for the Scarlet
Witch and a quick and and the vision was
totally eliminated it was gone
completely and so while this rift formed
ultimately the two of them split apart
and so what we find is that over the
course of the I guess the remaining
comics to comics leading up to Avengers
vol 3 issue number 12 in 1999 the two of
them basically operate on two different
levels the vision continues to write I
try to regain his humanity he tries to
regain what it is that made him unique
that made him a individual that could
really be something more than just an
Android
the Scarlet Witch of course continues
her actions and goes about her life
which again we cover a lot of this
during the during our video on the
Scarlet Witch but ultimately what
happens is that these circumstances lead
up to the Avengers disassembled event
and of course as we had talked about in
Avengers disassembled with our videos
the vision had appeared and the vision
had began coughing up various I guess
spheres and in turn these spheres turn
into versions of Ultron
attacking Avengers mansion but where
Marvel doesn't tell us here something
they've never explained to this day is
why it is this had happened this has
happened because the Scarlet Witch made
the vision do it or this has happened
because this was some kind of subroutine
programmed into the vision by Ultron if
the Avengers had ever sent out a white
call distress signal one was never given
us an answer to that question at this
point given the fact that the story's so
old I doubt they ever will now from here
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end the reason why is
because this is going to lead into the
model now event and of course with model
now Marvel had basically rebooted the
character of the vision they had
actually given him a new identity and
made him a new person entirely with that
being said we're gonna go ahead and ring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later
you